yeah good morning everyone welcome to
today's licensing subcommittee to
consider the application for a premises
license for the sim Mildred's Bay my
name is Charlotte Crowley and I'm acting
as the meeting facilitator and I will
conduct the election of the Chairman do
we have a nomination are nominate
councillor curry thank you is there a
second I'll second it okay excellent
Thank You councillor curry he's been
elected as the chairman of the licensing
subcommittee for today Thank You Sheila
welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee prior to this
meeting all participants have previously
checked that they can be heard and seen
you can see in here other members to
double-check this and to introduce
everyone who is present at this remote
meeting I would kindly ask that you
confirm your attendance and your role or
job title when I say your name
and so with Cancellara we know caps are
is here councillor Huxley hey I'm here a
gap in hat good morning everyone on the
committee's legal advisor thank you and
officers I'm Alison Alison's Mike's not
working at the moment so we're just
going to swap computers okay we know we
know she's here and Jane yes I'm here
goes a lot thank you and Katie line
Thank You Charles Shelton Gracie here
chosen ways here he's just talking to
mr. Cote Rahman thank you and
and Emily Emily's not with us today okay
and I also have them eivin dog smith
down here's the technical adviser he's
making sure our YouTube stream is fine
but he won't be joining us for the
actual meeting itself okay any button
like right Nick you know Nick said
Charlotte we have representatives from
the police all diamonds here licensing
cool legs up thank you and environmental
health thanks we have a represents
different Thank You Katie and out Paul
Glicksman it's Paul here mister
Glicksman could you unmute your
microphone yeah I'm here now thank you
and Michael King yes good morning mark
we can carry your licensing consultants
thank you and Sarah clover
good morning Sarah clover here I'm the
barrister who will be making the
representation on behalf of Mister
Glicksman
thank you thank you and I think that's
everyone now until the a members of the
public making representations we do we
have mister cultural not at present
German we're still trying to get him in
okay we'll come back mr. Cockrell sir
surely Thank You Nick miss Fitzgerald
sir miss Peltier if he if she could you
hum you too Mike Thank You mr. Hanks Ted
mr. hasting attendance thank you sir
Thank You mr. hasty and mr. Tapie I
don't believe you'd present chair okay
thank you Nick and I have a miss you'll
good morning thank you okay um have I
missed anybody no okay move on if you
have firm technical difficulties during
the meeting then please contact the
Democratic services officer on call
we'll attempt to assist you they'll put
their phone number in the chat function
on the right hand side I would ask
participants when you are not speaking
please mute your microphone this
minimizes background noise and will help
everyone in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak to gain my permission to speak
please very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen and I
will then make a note and go back to you
once the person speaking has finished
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls while in the meeting
is in progress do not turn off your
phones in case you need to be contacted
in the event of technical difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business and ensure
that you are in a quiet room free from
distraction
for the duration of this meeting please
know this meeting is being live-streamed
for members of the public except for the
private deliberation part of this
meeting in this instance a separate
private hangout meeting will take place
for that item only and the public
meeting will resume in its previous
digital location 30 minutes later unless
there is a reason to suggest an earlier
or later time no unauthorized recording
of the confidential item of business is
permitted to take place and moving on to
agenda item 2
apologies for absence are there any
other apologies for absence No okay
moving on to agenda item 3 declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest no we can move to agenda
item 4 application for premises license
some Mildred's Bay I now call upon
captain HAP her interim senior
litigation lawyer to explain to the
parties the procedure that they we will
be taking during the hearing thank you
thank you care that was occurring and
firstly the subcommittee will receive a
short factual summary of the application
for Madison rock of the Licensing
Authority and then the subcommittee will
consider the evidence in the following
order first the case on behalf of the
applicant mr. port Glicksman
who is represented by miss claw and the
coastal McGough the applicant or
licensed encoding calling of any
witnesses and then we'll follow the
questioning of the applicant eyes were
white and his witnesses by responsible
authorities and interested parties and
these are the environmental health
officer the place members of the public
making representations so that's mr.
rotter Cottrill miss lisa Fitzgerald
mr. diet they've hai said mister look
Italian miss Alison young and then
there'll be questioning of the applicant
and his witnesses by members of the
subcommittee and then we'll follow
Christ on behalf of the responsible
Authority making a representation so we
will be hearing first from the
Environmental Health Officer and then
after that the police but though the
procedure will be repeated for each
responsible Authority then we'll come
questioning of the responsible authority
by the applicant and then the interested
parties and then counselors and as I've
said that person will be repeated also
for the patient so a party can make
their representations locally then I am
available to be questioned by members by
other people making representations and
the abdicate and responsible authorities
and if finally they'll be subject to
questions I had members if there are any
and again this procedure will be
repeated for each interested party who
doesn't like representation and then
we'll come to something up on the
following order so each responsible
authority so there'll be the
environmental health officer in the
police and then each interested party
making representation and then finally
the applicant will like their proposal
submissions that kind of thing the
subcommittee will then retire and
consider the matter in private has
already been mentioned and I will as the
subcommittee's legal adviser really a
summary of the subcommittee's decision
and the written determination will be
circulated to all parties thank you
thank you Gavin
I would like to stress the importance of
following this hearing procedure and
that there'll be an opportunity for all
parties to make a final representation
presentation after questioning therefore
I would advise all those to please
follow the procedure and to respect
those speaking by not interrupting or
speaking over others if people do
interrupt of beak over others I as
chairman will ask them to refrain from
doing so if they continue to do so after
my warning then that individual could
face being asked to leave the meeting in
light of representations received the
variation is a request to remove to
current license conditions which can be
seen in part 1.1 of the report the
applicants for the premises license are
required as part of the application to
display a public notice and advertisers
at in a local paper these requirements
appear to have been complied with 20
representations were received from the
public one from urinal I and 2 were
rejected the Environmental Health
Department and the police have also
submitted representations one
representation was received in support
of the application the police have been
in discussions with the applicant and
have agreed to new conditions should the
current to be removed these can be found
in two point three of the report the
licensees subcommittee will be aware
that it must carry out its functions
under 2003 Licensing Act to take steps
which are appropriate for the promotion
of the licensing objectives the
licensing objectives are the prevention
of crime and disorder Public Safety the
prevention of public nuisance and the
protection of children from harm in
carrying out its licensing functions the
licensing subcommittee must also have
regard to its statement of the licensing
policy and guidance issued under the Act
the options for the subcommittee are
listed at the end of report in section 3
thank you Thank You Alison
now it comes to the applicants case with
the applicant and agents representative
please present their application
thank you very much counselor I'm going
to be presenting the application on
behalf of mr. Glicksman it's mr.
Glicksman license and mr. michael caine
who's also in this meeting is the
licensing consultant the licensing agent
if I can make the application first and
set out all the details about it and
commend it to you then going to ask mr.
Glicksman with your permission chair
just to say a few words at the end
because ultimately it's his license and
you might like to hear you and your
colleagues might like to hear some words
just just from him personally but if I
set up the technicalities as it were
this is an application to very two
conditions and that's quite important
because that focuses this hearing on
those two conditions in particular and I
think there might have been a little bit
of misunderstanding within some of the
representations as to the scope of what
this hearing might do in terms for
example of limiting hours or something
of that sort but it really is these two
conditions that we're focusing on you
have some written material in the pack
in the panel's pack on behalf of the
applicant there's some written material
in there that you'd be invited to read
and also there's a short statement a
written statement from mr. Glicksman
himself that was submitted in advance
that everybody has hopefully had the
chance to read and and I would also ask
the committee to to take a look at that
before reaching their decision and I
won't read it out I'm just going to pick
out some items from it these two
conditions really in substance it's just
the one condition and it is the issue
about having to have a table meal and
that's the wording in the condition
that's used with alcohol now the second
part of the condition condition that
goes with it it called an implied
condition that there will also be non
alcoholic beverages available now I
openness
the committee of course but I would
suggest that that's not really the
controversial part of any of this
hearing it's really about should alcohol
be tied to a table me on now that this
is a slightly old-fashioned condition
it's not commonly seen on licences up
and down the country anymore it was the
type of condition that was quite common
under the 1964 license
regime when licensing was dealt with by
the magistrates as you will know since
2005 if we've been under the Licensing
Act 2003 regime and that's how this
hearings been conducted and and very
often these sorts of conditions will
have been modernized and updated in in
that round of of change in 2005 and the
--scent Mildred's bay has had a license
since 2005 this isn't a knock today
application as it were the premises have
had a license for a long time now
actually this licensing authority and a
licensing has seen this license before
fairly recently there was an application
to vary the license in January of this
year
mr. Glicksman only took the cent
Mildred's bang on in in in late last
year late 2019 as an investment you may
know him as a local businessman he has
other premises in the town he's got a
pool of bistro which is quite useful
certainly useful from the responsible
authorities point of view because they
have a chance to observe and test him as
a responsible businessman within the
community and I'll say a few words about
the other premises in just a moment but
mr. Glicksman
took on the sin Mildred's very fairly
late last year before we were confronted
with this a corona virus pandemic and
all of the terrible consequences that
have come with that and the purpose for
taking on what was previously a cafe
maybe people won't be offended if I call
it slightly tired it needed some TLC it
came on the market mr. Glicksman took it
on and his ambition for it
at that time was to turn it into a
high-class restaurant the application
came in in January still before this
Kovac 19 pandemic hit to extend the
premises to extend the area that the
license applied to to extend the hours
to extend the takeaway that application
came up in March
still just before the the lockdown here
and it was granted and that's quite
important to note because that's the
context of this application and what
really should have happened in that
hearing in March is that these two
conditions should have been considered
at the same time and that that's not to
point fingers anybody mr. king did not
put in the application in January it was
a different agent it was considered in
March it couldn't be added on in March
so we've effectively split that
application from March and now into
these two parts but these conditions go
together with the takeaway ability of
these premises to trade and in actual
fact that was extended as I say in in
March now for the specific part of this
condition that's under consideration
that alcohol can only be taken with a
meal a table meal I'm going to ask the
committee to consider now in the context
of what this license is what actually
means having been granted a takeaway
facility for these premises what how
will the table meal be described at the
moment of course it's not possible for
anybody to have what might traditionally
be described as a table meal to go into
the premises and sit down with a knife
and fork that quickly isn't possible for
any license primitives at this time
because of the pandemic situation that
we're facing
well the premises are all allowed to do
and what most licensed premises up and
down the country are now allowed to do
with the government's approval is to
provide takeaway and that that's really
for survival purposes as you will
understand businesses are under enormous
pressure hospitality businesses in
particular are under enormous pressure
it's a very sad fact
with a large percentage of our
hospitality businesses will not survive
pandemic the government has obviously
appreciated that that harsh fact and is
doing everything that it can to protect
and preserve businesses because we need
them to reignite the economy once we are
able to come out of this lockdown in
this this situation take away provision
for licensed premises was one of the
things that the government stepped in to
allow in terms of planning permission to
say well you for this period of time you
don't need special Planning Commission
to do that thing so what is that he's
allowed to do even now from a planning
and a licensing point of view is to
provide at a quarry facility from these
premises and he is allowed to provide
let's say a hot dog or a hamburger or
something like that with alcohol that
people take away he would not be
permitted to provide the alcohol on its
own now in that context the conditions
make very little sense and in terms of
varying this condition what I really
want to commend to you the message I
really want to emphasize this morning is
that it what the condition or the
wording of the condition that preserves
the behavior of customers it's the
management you you may well appreciate
that
tying alcohol with food there's no
particular guarantee in and of itself of
how people behave you may well have come
across even being at parties where
people are eating food food is available
and and yet people are not on their best
behavior having had a drink or whatever
it is it's not about forcing people to
eat while they're drinking it's a
question of management it's a question
of the class and the caliber of the
premises those Wagle if the premises are
a Class C nature and that's the
expectation placed upon them and star
for well-trained and the management are
on top of their game and so forth and
that brings me back to mr. Glickman's
are the premises within the town Paul's
Bistro because there
you have a working example of the kind
of manager the kind of operator that
Nick's Minh is he has another set of
premises that you can judge him by that
the police and environmental health can
judge him by that does not have this
condition it doesn't tie alcohol and
food there are no difficulties it's not
a question that mr. Blake's Minister
ever had any problems ever had any
complaints the police have not had cause
to deal with incidents at the premises
or anything of that sort that that's not
the nature of concern so really looking
at this condition for this license it's
about fear of what might happen if this
condition is relaxed but the purpose of
relaxing the condition of course in the
immediate term is this ability to
survive and that's very very important
that the number of premises that will
not survive if the Kogan 19 situation is
quite terrifying and that's very
important from a local economy point of
view and you have in your pack some of
your corporate priorities and I want to
touch on those at the end because they
they tie into this so take away in the
immediate term is it is a very important
part of this application as the
Glicksman has his hands tied and then
there may be ramifications over the next
few months that that mean that the
business is struggling entirely so in
terms of some of the concerns and the
fears that have been expressed by
residents those do not have immediate
application nobody is drinking or eating
inside the premises and that would be
unlikely to be happening on any view
until towards the end of the year
possibly even into 2021
so I'm asking the committee to consider
this application at this point in time
in that respect of the conditions that
currently pertain and I'll say this now
and I'll also say the ending must never
be forgotten that the licensing regime
works on a light touch basis because
there is the facility for a review and
the police understand this there are
multiple authorities licensing authority
Environmental Health understand this
is never a question of the licensing
getting out of control because if there
are any particular issues any particular
concerns arising from any element of the
operation that premises it is always
possible for any of the responsible
authorities or indeed the residents
themselves to come back with a review
application and say actually that part
isn't working so that's something to
consider but in the future the change in
this condition is also very important
because the mystical excellence vision
and aspirations for these premises which
are very important the the purpose of
taking on the premises the purpose of
investing in the first place was to
transform them to really restore
premises in a prime location that could
do so much for tourism produce so much
for the local economy he has a planning
application that's been granted that
would see significant glass frontage a
very beautiful glass balustrade really
transforming the premises into somewhere
attractive and appealing for people to
sit look out across the bay look out
across the sea and to draw people to
that facility in in a controlled and a
welcoming fashion and that's that's a
good thing very similar to the operation
of the Bistro which is only about half
half a mile away there's something on
the table there was at the time of the
purchase of the premises like two
hundred thousand pounds worth of
investment that was proposed for these
premises the planning application has
been made and has been granted and
that's also very important because for
some of the representations that the
members of the public that residents are
making those will also have been
considered at the time of the grant of
the planning application now I
understand of course as a professional
practitioner that licensing and planning
are different however there comes a
point where they cross over and when you
make a planning application officers
will be looking at issues such as noise
disturbance anti-social behavior are
these the right premises in there
place should they benefit from the
planning application that has been made
all of these things will be considered
in terms of the planning application so
that there are important crossovers
there in terms of the proposal for the
economy a number of the residents have
said this is a quiet area this is an
area for residents and particularly
retirees it's very important to balance
local economies as the committee will
know a seaside town such as Westgate
will need a balance of their monographic
it can't just be a place for people to
come and live and live quietly and
retire and so forth there is a need for
local business there is a need for local
economy there is the need for tourism
there's a need jobs and job
opportunities there's a need or
opportunity for young people and all of
these things have to be considered at
the same time mister Glicksman as I hope
you've picked up from his statement is a
well establishment he has been in West
Gate on C for some thirty nine years and
he's been in the hospitality industry
for something like eighteen years so he
is a huge credit to the local community
and the local economy and he deserves
that support and he has that support he
has that support from local councilors
and he has that support from need from
the town council he is in and of himself
a significant contributor to the local
economy
listen Mildred's Bay currently employs
something like 14 employees that will
increase at such a time that business
picks up that business is improved after
this his lockdown situation he employs
something similar at the Paul's
Bistro these are significant numbers in
terms of local employment he also has a
commendable reputation as a local
businessman he's involved in local
charity work he sits with the West gates
like committee at which you no doubt
no and is involved in Westgate day I'm
getting messages coming through that in
fact the planning has not been granted
yet so I retract that comment and I
apologized for it that's my
misunderstanding I thought that he had
in any event I flipped that comment then
around to say they are full of
considerations that will be taken into
account in planning so far as the
license is concerned essentially the
ability for these premises to trade with
me with the aspects that I've
highlighted that the plan that will be
used was completed in March so it's
effectively the other way around then
that licensing have already approved the
operation these premises with the vision
that mystic Lake Simone has if that has
yet to go through planning then
conversely the committee has the
reassurance that as I've said exactly
the same considerations must be taken
into account
residential amenity noise are these the
right premises in the right place though
to a certain extent then the committee
can relax and say those are
considerations for for the other
committee returns specifically to the
representations that have been made that
the residents representations that have
been made I understand the similar
number around about 20 objections that
were made in March and it seems that a
number of the things that have been
raised in me in the representations were
similar sports the points that were made
and not accepted by the committee in
March there's quite a lot for example
about that these hours are inappropriate
well ours as you would appreciate our or
a settled matter at this point that
that's not what this committee is being
asked to look at but though the reason
behind the representations the call fear
behind the representations is that these
premises with the single change of this
condition will turn into a pub or a
nightclub or a late night destination
and that that's simply not the case the
premises will remain exactly in
accordance with mr. Dixon's vision
exactly in accordance with the changed
application for the license that came in
and was considered in March exactly in
accordance with the planning application
this is a restaurant
based proposal it's a restaurant based
operation of a high-class caliber so the
food that will be on offer is
significantly superior to what was being
offered previously and the the
reputation of the premises that already
has been noted to be significantly
improved it's not a pub it's not
intended to be a pub and removing that
condition on its own as I've said would
not make it into one a number of the
concerns that residents are raising are
not logically connected to this change
in condition so some of the points that
have been made and let me say at the
outset then of course residents concerns
are always to be taken very seriously
these are the people who live and work
in the area this is my er area as well I
completely understand and respect that
nothing I'm saying is intended to
dismiss these concerns in any way but
what I hope I can do is to demonstrate
these concerns will not manifest
themselves in real life and there are a
number of reasons for that the nature of
what residents are concerned about in
terms of increase in traffic for example
or increase in noise at dispersal or
increase in anti-social behavior there's
no particular reason to believe you that
the amendments of this condition would
have any of those consequences flowing
from it people will plan the premises at
this point in time in a different way of
course because we're in a lockdown
situation but even rolling forward we're
at a time where people can attend the
premises in the way that's intended
there's no reason to believe that they
will attend the premises in a different
way because they can or cannot have food
or cannot cannot have alcohol with their
food the the attendance the capacity of
the premises will be the same that the
people who are likely to want to attend
will be the same the simple change in
this condition is not the element that
would give rise to the issues that the
residents are concerned like if anything
these are the thoughts of concerns and
consideration that will have been taken
into account by the last committee when
they approved an extension of the
premises and they approved an extension
in the hours that's the point at which
one way to expect
did any well-founded concerns about a
change in the visiting pattern to have
been taken into account and it's clearly
been concluded that that would not occur
this additional change won't change that
so when residents talk about whether
might be later deliveries or deliveries
to the premises or that there might be
more traffic and so on but that's that's
not a conclusion that would flow from
this particular change and as I've
indicated the the responsibility of
people consumers around alcohol tends to
depend upon the type of place they're
going to and the behavior that's
expected upon over there and for mister
Glicksman that's really not going to be
an issue now there are additional
concerns about how people are likely to
behave in the open space how they're
going to behave on the beach John
they're going to be unruly on the beach
having obtained alcohol and there's a
particular issue with litter when I come
to the police representation you look or
see that that was what was the key
concern of the police as to how people
would behave in the public realm under
any danger around glass on the glass
issue has been taken care of
comprehensively with a condition that
there will not be take away glass mr.
Glickman doesn't have a problem with
that all take away alcohol can be
provided in receptacles that will not
contain people and won't be made of
glass even a bottle of warning box or
something of that sort can be supplied
in plastic so there's another question
of glass at all and the containers a can
in certain circumstances also be
biodegradable in terms of people going
on to the beach with alcohol and
misbehaving well of course it's a fact
of life that if people are prepared to
do that kind of thing if they want
the only thing they can obtain alcohol
from a local convenience store or a
supermarket if that is their intent and
it is actually preferable for people who
buy alcohol if that is what they want to
do to sit on the beach to have a bottle
of beer with their sandwich or whatever
else it is it is better that they go and
procure it from a local business with
responsible staff who can judge whether
that's they ought to be made who can
judge whether that person has
ready hug too much alcohol and they're
not going to get any more so it is not a
question of refusing the condition for
that reason but we want people primarily
to obtain their alcohol from responsible
premises that can apply the Chapman
controls underage Jake's checking people
sober and so forth it is a very very
important point in this case that the
responsible authorities by and large are
satisfied with this application there
was a very careful consideration at the
police you have I think copies of the
exchange of corresponds with the
policeman honestly often the demon will
comment in due course but an agreement
was reached with the police that the the
premises would be well-run as long as
there was no glass as I've indicated and
that takeaways terminated at 10 o'clock
2200 hours now that that's more than an
opinion because that is the conclusion
of a responsible authority and you will
know from the section 182 guidance and
you will know from from other sources
but the advice of the police the
professional opinion of the police about
issues of anti-social behaviour crime
and disorder ought to be taken
particularly seriously they ought to be
given significant weight and unless
there's specific evidence that the
conclusion of the police is wrong for
some reason then that is a position that
the committee are invited to take very
seriously and similarly the licensing
authority as a responsible authority is
capable of putting in an objection if
they see any issues which they might if
they thought this was an irresponsible
licensee or the here on are the premises
irresponsibly or anything of that sort
and you don't have that representation
from the licensing authority or indeed
from Trading Standards or from any other
quarter other than environmental health
and I will come on to that in just a
moment so it's very important as I said
to consider that the totality of this
situation we do have case law that
indicates that a licensing like this is
really a 360 degree exercise and you are
quite entitled perfectly entitled to
take into account and the impact
the input on on the local economy I
mentioned your corporate
responsibilities which you had to miss
out at the front of your report and for
for some of those looking at the local
job situation looking at the resilience
of the economy our particular priorities
that the council has said that it will
take into account and so I do invite the
council to do that very thing and the
representation on your page ninety nine
from coastal development in the tourism
scene which I think includes comments
from the RNLI on this occasion raised
some concerns which I'd invite you to
could have in fact will be met and
particularly with the approval of the
police in terms of any and glass on the
beach or any anti-social behavior on a
beach the page 103 the Town Council's
representation has been categorized as
supportive and they do say that they
support the Glicksman
and mister Glicksman has certainly
experienced that support from the Town
Council but then we have also raised the
issue of powers which I have indicated
at the beginning of its representation
it is not actually something that's
currently before this committee so our
deal with me representation from
environmental health no it appears that
environmental health have effectively
repeated the objection that they placed
before the committee on the last
occasion so there's an element of
confusion there because that the phrase
in this current objection about in line
with their last rejection actually
that's apples and pears we are dealing
with something very different we are
dealing specifically with this condition
an environmental health have put forward
an objection on the basis of these are
the wrong premises in the wrong place
well that that's not a consideration for
this committee today that goes too far
if I may respectfully say so those are
perhaps some of the considerations that
environmental health could raise with
the Planning Department the Planning
Committee if that application is still
going through as it clearly is but in
terms of location not suitable for a
late drinking establishment well the
premises are there and the hours offset
so that isn't in fact something that
that in
mental health can present to to this
committee today so I'm not entirely
clear and I doubt they will explain what
the particular concerns are about me the
condition which is what we aren't here
for I am going to pause there for a
moment and I wonder if I can just ask
through you chair
if mr. Glickman would add a few words as
I say he has put in his statement and he
has described not only his background in
the cloud but also his aspirations for
these promises but if I could just ask
him at this moment to say a few more
words about that to you that's fine yeah
good morning everybody and as you're
probably aware I had run those were on
Bistro for the last 18 months and done
it very successfully and I had no issues
whatsoever with anything whatsoever I
keep really touchy and I don't have any
trouble whatsoever and and I'm gonna do
exactly the same at some Mildred's and
we don't have it's mainly the older
clientele that we get there we don't get
the young kids that want the cheap drink
that's not what we want to do that's not
where we come from you know we want to
do with no asset clientele that sort of
want to come in and have it enjoyable
evening we don't want a nightclub there
I don't want a bar with lots of hourly
people we're not doing anything like
that
all we wanted to do is have a really
lovely premises that's going to serve
whiskey and be a credit to Westgate and
nothing else really you know I do really
run a tight ship you know I don't have
any trouble whatsoever that pulls and
the first time to trouble the about I
don't know anything like that happen and
I'll do exactly the same we have great
staff who really mindful of this and
everybody gets checked on page if they
do come in the younger ones and we're
really strict you know we don't want you
know the people that come in like we
lots of and females that that come in
and from sales come in because of the
way that we run our business and we're
gonna do exactly the same it's a
Mildred's so you've got absolutely
there's no reason to be concerned about
how the prices will be rocking over run
it is that clear the same that's it
Thank You mr. dicks man okay thank you
I'm going to pause there thank you very
much indeed for your time that that is
the application and I know there'll be
an opportunity to sum up in due course
so thank you very much indeed thank you
very much for your presentation thus the
licensing team have any questions for
the applicants no we don't thank you
thank you
I do environmental health have any
questions for the applicants you will
also have an opportunity to present your
case but if you have any questions
please stay and now I'm from
environmental protection and the
question that I had really was in
relation to Paul's bar paws Bistro as
it's been referred to now I understand
that the this new resume is going to be
one in the same way as paws is that
correct I'm going to pick up on on a
specific point like that that's okay
well in the fact that we're going to do
obviously a different quality of food
and we will yeah in a pretty similar way
I it's not going to be a nightclub and
we don't run pulses micro we will have
you know we through attends license we
will do some events but obviously
they'll be pre-warned to the council and
to the local residents like you know if
we have like a singer on a Saturday
evening you'll be inside the singer you
know we're not going to have anything
external we've got that agreement that
that no those are because the 9:00 p.m.
with the music wouldn't go on like
certain sort of if we have a singer it's
sort of ten o'clock if that they finish
anyway
yeah we don't I don't want to have a
nightclub there that's not what I want
to say on the on the facts of it being
run in the same way as opposed is that
we are aware that as you've already said
sometimes there's themed evenings
functions like musics parties and
obviously that will bring complaints
which we have received about Paul in the
past not in relation to young patrons or
rowdy behavior as in you know you
stopping people from coming in however
we have had complaints relation to
patron noise which can be caused by any
person you know unsophisticated and also
about the loud music external loud music
live bands and obviously this is
something that concerns me that could be
happening at City memories by NASA built
some new trees by it's quite a lot
larger where it would be be able to have
the bat internally unless it was an
actual event through a tenth license and
so I'm not gonna have loads of music
those bands out outside because it is
probably double the size of poles which
means that I would be able to contain it
within sight inside the building looking
to do I would like to say it's obviously
the logistic the area office at
Mildred's Bay is completely different
with the high street in West Gate so
although the building would be larger I
would have concerns that there is no
other noise source particularly in the
area you know there's no trains traffic
you know other other establishments so I
would be concerned about noise that's
been caused as you know you know I have
those concerns There is obviously next
door is Milly's and they do have live
events as well and that they seem to
work okay I know that they have DJs and
I know that they have life's innocent
and we're going to be no different to
them move it'll be controlled in a sort
of a really helpful way that you know we
don't want to accept the locals we read
one work with them yeah sure can I ask
as well and how that will be controlled
because in the application and
licensing objective for the Prevention
of public nuisance it said that no steps
were identified that were not already
covered under these or other legislation
so I just wondered if you are changing
it from a restaurant to a drinking
establishment of how you know why no new
steps would be necessary something no I
shouldn't salsa restaurants all right
I'm not sure I'm following the question
in all honesty chair may I pick up on
this question because I do have some
concerns and I've dropped one of them in
the chat room this is not about the
application in terms of noise and and
events these are matters that will have
been taken into consideration on the
last occasion when the extension of ours
was being considered for the for the
license overall what the committee is
considering exclusively today can
everybody hear me yes yeah sorry the
screens are frozen I just wondered if
everybody were still hearing me at what
weakness sitting today is exclusively
where there alcohol must be served with
a table meal that is the only
consideration in front of this committee
so unfortunately miss lungs questions
are not something that this committee
can rule upon and I make a formal legal
submission on that on the regulation 18
that their licensing hearings
regulations 2005 so it is not a light
matter in terms of noise events and what
mr. Glickman can or cannot do that
that's settled and comparisons with
Paul's bar are therefore inappropriate
and I also take formal exception to any
reference to complaints that have been
made that are not in the environmental
health representation evidence has not
been given it is not permissible to add
things to a representation in the middle
of a hearing and I also invoke
regulation 18 on that as well
thank you
is there any further representation from
environmental health
ah Katie Lane seems to have left the
meeting okay let's move on how do the
police have any questions for the
applicants no I don't mean you anyone
sorry could I just come in to say
everything needs to be through the
meeting and not in the chat yes thank
you okay yeah so you have my question
that do the police have any questions
for the applicant no mr. Chairman I do
not have any questions it's monkey time
thank you thank you very much
do the members of the public making
representations have any questions for
the applicant
I will come to each objector in turn by
name please ask only relevant questions
if you do not have any questions please
say no questions I would remind members
of the public making representations
this is not the point in the meeting to
state your case or opinions this will
come later please stick at the moment to
asking questions mr. Roger Cottrill do
you have any questions for the
applicants mr. Cotterell
Oh Nick torture taken very very fine
like they should be couple of Atlanta
thing yeah
I couldn't quite hear the whole question
mr. cultural but I gather that this was
concerning ours was the premises would
that be correct
yeah I think this is a question about an
hour's which screen we not really
relevant so this actually meeting okay
and what would mr. Glicksman or on his
clothing like to respond to that I'm
very sorry I didn't get that lets I'm
sorry mr. culturally it was such a bad
connection I'll have to move on mr.
Venus Fitzgerald do you have any
questions for the applicants Thank You
mr. Dave hasted do you have any
questions not at this time thank you
Thank You mr. hosted he's a mister type
in here no I don't think so
moving on and miss Alison you'll do you
have any questions for the applicants no
I'm thank you thank you okay that's
that's all the members of the public
there
members of the committee do you have any
questions for the applicant yeah I do
mr. chair just quickly Thank You counsel
yes cancer Huxley I'm just saying Sarah
cloaca you sort of explained about can
you just explain again bit and clearly
why did the applicant not bring this
variation that we're talking about now
with when you brought the original
variation in March that was to increase
the opening hours it seems a bit
stranger you didn't put the two together
some of the residents might think that
was suspicious or something can you
explain a bit more freely thank you yes
I can and it is a very good question and
there's nothing suspicious about it
unfortunately mr. Glicksman hasn't been
well served by that situation he had an
age and who devised the application for
him back in January it wasn't something
that mr. Kane had anything to do with
and it wasn't something that I had
anything to do with but the agent at
that time simply didn't join up the dots
didn't make the connection that if
you're going to have takeaway and you're
going to extend takeaway and extend
then you need to go through these
conditions as well and obviously this
condition represents an ambiguity and a
roadblock to the application that was
made in March it simply wasn't picked up
on and it should have been but it's it
becomes an anomaly now even to the
extent as I said it's not clear what it
means if you can have takeaways
but you must only have alcohol with the
table meal what what isn't Weibull meal
this is the point that I made earlier it
actually doesn't make any sense so we
have a condition on the license now that
is meaningless
and unenforceable that's key but that
would make you an unlawful condition so
you're absolutely right it should have
been dealt with at the last occasion
it just wasn't and that was really the
fault of the application in January you
you can't make changes like that when it
actually comes to the committee in March
that's changing the application too much
and trying to extend it too much so it
just couldn't be dealt with at that
stage and that's why I further
application has that to be made like
this okay thank you
and could I ask the licensing members of
staff what they what the sort of their
different definition of what a table
meal and alcohol mean or was that not
part of its can you sort of give a
definition what the legislation actually
means thank you I can't quite hear you
at the moment penny
I sorry Tara something wrong with
pennies the volume um are you happy for
us to answer that question because
obviously the questions at the moment
should be of the app content more
questions from the committee
can I ask mr. Glicksman and when were
the two conditions originally applied
the two conditions when were they
applied for when were they actually
issued when when they put on the
premises these two conditions I think
that they was already in place I when I
purchased the premises the conditions
were there
when we push in the application to bury
the tines with a guy who was
representing me at the beginning but
obviously it wasn't really that the
right person for the job and I soon
realized that that's when I and moved
and asked Michael to represent me at the
last case and it was then that we
realized that they were still fooled on
that on the license that shouldn't have
been there that's when obviously we've
now had to obviously a great expense of
children under rather have dealt with it
all in the March hearing you know for me
would have been much better to get it
all done
you know you there was no reason for us
to do this they shouldn't have been
really other than it was an error from
the guy who's who was representing me
from the January application was it was
a huge error that was the reason why
we're now where we are today okay Thank
You Janet oh and if I can assist in
relation to when the conditions will
have gone on the license the license was
granted in 2005 which would have been a
conversion presumably over from from a
previous license under the 1964 regime
these look to me like carryover
conditions it looks like an attempt just
to replicate what the license used to be
in
to a new license when when the Act came
in that that's that's what my eye is
telling me I don't know your licensing
officers will probably know whether
there was any change again to that
license from 2005 until mr. Glickman
took it on and made his application in
in January I I suspect not that it's the
language of the old 1964 Act this one
table meals okay thank you very much
okay there's no more questions from the
committee I'd like to ask invite the
Environmental Health Officer if she's
still here whether she would like to
present their case yes thank you okay
yeah so good morning everyone my name is
Katie nigh many appointments of
protection of sir I've read the
application to remove the two conditions
of the license and I'm objects and it's
on the grounds of prevention of public
nuisance he is important when
considering the promotion of this
licensing objective that licensing and
responsible authorities focus on the
effect of the life support activities
are the specific premises on persons
living and working in the area around
the premises which may be
disproportionate and unreasonable my
concerns are around noise nuisance the
premises as we know has since the grant
of the license in 2005 has been
generally used at daytime Beach Cafe
used between 9:00 and 5:00 and it's
never actually been used to full extent
of the license that was gone at this
time so the conditions imposed on the
license allowed the premises to operate
as a restaurant if these conditions are
removed it will become a more of a
drinking establishment and with the
recent change to the operation chimes
the drinking will go on into the early
hours of the morning I also know that
there has been a planning application
submitted as we've discussed which
requests a change of views for an a3 to
adjoin a three-stroke
a4 and I just like to clarify that an a3
use is for restaurants and cafe
Rosanne a4 use includes public-houses
wine bars and other drinking
establishments so this shows that the
move is being made to a drinking
establishment as the conditions imposed
restricts use to the out of a restaurant
recently as sarah has explained me we've
had a hearing and in March on that
hearing condition was added to the
license which required all windows and
doors to be closed after 9:00 this was
to reduce possible noise emanating from
inside the premises
however I've always had concerns about
the external courtyards as noise from
this area would be very difficult to
control with a intersection one of the
revised guidance and more specifically
section 2.1 bit of which states the
conditions relating to noise nuisance or
usually concerned stepped appropriate to
control the level of noise emanating
from the premises this may be achieved
by a simple measure such as closing the
windows and doors which obviously they
already have or not permitting use of
garden areas at this time and I would
reiterate that this is when I'm really
concerned about the noise nuisance that
could be caused and so in light the
guidance I have laced with Michael and I
did offer a condition to control this
area which would be the service and
consumption of alcohol in the courtyard
is restricted to 9:00 p.m. daily
so that is in line with the windows and
doors everybody you know being closed
this was not not agreed the conditionals
agreed and so just to reach out I have
grave concerns about the noise pollution
being caused in the area and my
objections in this representation and
not going to protect the residents in
the area but also the applicant who
would be open to noise nuisance could be
open to noise nuisance complaints once
fully operational you'd also note the
level of objections we see II that
concerns a widespread and I would
reiterate that the nearest residential
properties only 10 meters away from the
premises I feel that removing the
conditions will change the logistics of
the premises
the condition I feel helps prevent
public nuisance this ends my
representation thank you miss lane does
the applicant or agent have any
questions for the environmental health
officer just one through you chair if I
may that miss lane this is essentially
the same objection that environmental
health presented to the March committing
concerns about noise pollution yes they
haven't both gone away and I feel the
taking those conditions off I'm just
going to ask again the matter even
further well I'll deal with that part in
submissions but that was my question
thank you thank you Jeff
thank you okay um do the members of the
public making representations have any
questions for the environments who
health officer I'll come to each
objector in turn by name please ask only
relevant questions if you do not have
any questions please say no questions
I'd remind members of the public making
representations this is not the point in
the meeting to state your case or
opinions this will come later please
stick to just asking questions mr. Roger
Cottrill - any questions for the
environmental health officer thank you
Miss Sally's Fitzgerald did you have any
questions Thank You mr. David hasted no
questions thank him thank you David and
Mister taping his not hearing and miss
Allison you'll have you any questions
for the environmental health orbiter my
question thank you thank you do members
of the committee have any questions for
the environmental health officer no I
don't have any chair thank you thank you
I don't have any thank you thank you
very much
but there with the police like to
present their case now please yes up to
members of the committee in the panel
I'm like to submit the police case from
the odd documentation you should have
received the police evidence or their
form of representation towards this
question the pharmacist had been used
since 2005 under the new Licensing Act
2003 as predominantly a cafe come
restaurants I agree from the authorities
environmentally then this has not been
used to its full capacity
however in 2020 and March application
was received by the police to allow
ourselves on these premises the police
had no evidence and could not produce
evidence as anything would be hearsay at
the time of the hearing however during
they had leave negotiation terms of this
one a lot of things have come to lights
I accept from mr. glitzmas own reports
and from Sara clover this was purchased
as an investment the investments of
these premises clearly states that
something else was going to happen the
removal of conditions and allowing off
sales was the start
however that starts was clear from local
residents point of view of causing
concern is the police licensing
authority can only talk on crime and to
seeing disorder prevention upfront
disorder therefore from my report you
have seen that I suggested two
conditions that could be put in place to
alleviate the concerns of the police
that is rubbish on the beach
potential for harm to local residents
causing crime disorder
I'd like to refer to the reports
evidence given by the applicants I have
a fully understood and read the Hope and
Glory
public-house limited mercies city of
westminster licensed incisions often in
involved wearing a variety of completely
competing considerations did you want at
the licensing establishments the
economic benefits of the pepper the
proprietor and the locality of drawing
in visitors and stimulating the demands
this effects on local law and order the
impacts must be considered of the life
of those who live and work in the
vicinity and so on if I'm going to the
full thing however this of this case
does not take away public human rights
mr. Richmond has invested in these
premises greatly and has established the
business and whether we are considering
the premises of license the license at
the present moment could quite rightly
returned from a cafe restaurant into a
public house or even dare I say it's a
late night venue which has an impact on
crime and disorder I have therefore
asked for these these conditions to be
added to the list which mr. King has
agreed to with a variation I've asked
the 1900 hours and they have asked for
2200 hours
the police are willing to accept the
2200 hours to protect local residents
hopefully I would like really to give
this moment to the local residents who
live there I that's the police lodges
authority have no evidence to say what
could and what will happen I can only
work on facts and facts of evidence
therefore I would like to present that
as the police representations to this
application removing these conditions
will have an effect from local
communities and removing these
conditions will give the rights to mr.
Glickman to operate as a club and or
late-night venue so the conditions stand
as I have evicted in my report thank you
thank you very much that the applicant
or agent or representative have any
questions for the police no I'll just
make submission thank you very much
indeed
thank you do members of the public
making representations of any questions
for the police or come to each objects
in turn by name please ask only roaming
questions I'd remind them that with the
public making representations this is
not the point in the meeting state your
case this would come later please stick
to asking questions mr. cultural driven
questions for the police go ahead mr.
Cockrell
use me mr. cultural I'm once again the
reception the signal is so bad I'm
afraid we can't hear what you're saying
I'm sorry about that chairman may I make
a suggestion play yeah if you move on to
the next person that's going to make a
representation if mr. Cockrell writes
his question in the chat function on the
side of the screen then I as the officer
may read that out on his behalf
would that be an acceptable solution to
you yes that perfectly acceptable Thank
You Nick
is that okay mr. cultural thank you for
that you're moving on miss Elise
Fitzgerald have you any questions for
the police no questions thank you thank
you mr. David hasted any questions for
the police yes please thank you it's
wondering why'd you into request was or
ten o'clock as a limit you've actually
agreed to so you agreed you requested
seven [ __ ] sleep you agreed to Tempe
in going through the chair if I may
respond to that yes please have a
negotiation we are working both the
local residents with the country with
the agents and the applicants to get the
best we can we are producing evidence if
we can't produce evidence from kathy
negotiations compromise between 10:00
o'clock and 1900 hours Senate clock was
accepted as a reasonable aimed as
night's he said the reason why I've
asked for the hours 9:00 at 1300 hours
and 2000 to 2200 hours was I did not
want to see I will pick up a point from
Seraph over on this I do not want to see
people using the convene
of these establishments to obtain
further stocks about all to be taken
onto the beach which is more convenient
to do that it is inconvenient to walk up
the roads to purchase some we're not
licensed or another establishment there
are the quantities of them alcohol and
bring them down to the beach this is a
point of the negotiation believe I've
accepted that
thank you you're happy with that mr.
hasted yes thank you thank you mr.
Allison you'll do you have any questions
for the police my question thank you
thank you very much the members of the
committee of any questions for the
police no I don't have any questions
chair thank you okay just just to
confirm the these two new conditions
would be no off sales from tenían
morning till 10:00 in the evening and
mum laughs they'd be there two
conditions mr. Berman the conditions are
as stated however you the committee Oh
Bardot better it speaks as the time to
negotiation the last day of
representation took place these
negotiations were put in place there for
local residents did not have the option
of understanding what conditions have
been accepted by the police therefore I
am bringing it to the committee for
ratification you the committee have the
right to either amend change or refuse
those conditions at this voted stage
thank you this is the point of the
meeting at which remembered sorry yeah
mr. cultural yeah just to confirm that
mr. Cockrell has confirmed that his
question to the police has already been
asked by mr. hasty so he won't be asking
a further question thank you
this is the point of the meeting at
which the members of the public making
representations will get to do so I will
ask each objector in turn to make the
representation can members of the public
making representations please refrain
from repeating the points made by
previous speakers I'll then allow
questions from the applicant relevant
authorities and members of the committee
once all members of the public making
representations have done so mister
Elise Fitzgerald please can you make
your representation or would you would
you like to make a representation miss
Fitzgerald not at this time thank you
okay thank you and mr. hasted would you
like to make representation yes please
okay go ahead no it's not to matter for
the hearing the agent referred at some
length to the application we request for
a change to a bar removal of these two
conditions and the licensing will turn
the premises for a restaurant to a
public bar with a late-night license
which will lead to an increased public
nuisance from customers leaving the
premises I don't I read that whilst
accepting that the current pandemic is
an unusual situation it is hoped is
going to be a temporary major and I
don't believe it should be considered
that make a decision dissidents and many
years to come thank you
Thank You Christine mr. Allison you'll
would you like to make a representation
yeah thank you please go ahead I just
like to say really the removing of his
condition will have a huge impact on
this area and I feel unfortunately not
for the better all the reasons stated in
various
statements today well so now you say mr.
Glickman that you've invested heavily in
this new venture equally we have all
invested in buying our apartments and
these there there is now potential for
the loss of value when a bar could be 20
foot away from these apartments
simply put would you buy an apartment
now that was prime position we receive
you in a choir area when suddenly you're
going to have a pub in front of you or
equally where you currently live how
would you feel if you and your neighbors
had a pub 20-foot from your premises
Thank You Monsieur is the applicant or
agent have any questions for any of the
members of the public making
representations thank you yeah do
environmental health have any questions
for the members of the public making
representations thank you sorry to
interject chairman of the mr. Cockrell
obviously was a person that was making
representation I appreciate that mr.
Cockrell is having some issues with his
microphone but I think it would be fair
to give him the opportunity to at least
try and I would ask mr. cultural to
speak up quite loudly if 20 objectors
must come to the conclusion
yes thank you
Thank You mr. cultural do an
environmental elk many questions for the
members of the public making
representations do the police have any
questions for the members of the public
make the representations do I don't
thank you thank you do members of the
committee have any questions for members
of the public environmental cause even
when people have eaten however in
general we Environmental Health receive
less complaints about patient and music
noise from restaurants and they do to
solve the noise associated with this
change will creat will cause increased
pollution I would remind you of my
suggested condition to restrict the
service and consumption of alcohol to
the outside area until 9 p.m. if the
removal of these conditions is granted I
would urge the committee of the
inclusion of this condition thank you
thank you thank you miss lane
and what the police like to make a
formal statement so we'll do that the
president promises license was agreed by
the District Council and a hearing on
the 3rd of March 2020 removing these two
conditions will have the effect of fully
removing the cafe and restaurants option
of these facilities and therefore turn
them into more of a kinder to a pub of
they are sites and late-night venue
which would be more suitable for a town
center rather than a sleepy seaside cafe
environments
many of the local residents are elderly
and therefore on the human rights would
lose their benefits to live in peace and
quiet in their latter years the place
have requested a number of conditions to
hopefully mitigate against these effects
to local residents however the committee
has the right to amends or increase
those conditions if required thank you
very much thank you with the what the
interesting part is namely the members
of the public making representations
like to make their final comments mr.
Roger Cottrill would you like to make a
final comment
Thank You mr. Gerald we like to make
comments yes thank you
and similitudes Bay is very unique as it
is a bathe is very quiet very
family-orientated frequented by locals
by changing the license would massively
affect this Bay and our mental health
and well-being this is an area that we
all love and the community is strong and
we don't need a late-night establishment
here Oakland late night establishments
we welcome a lovely business on the
seafront that you know serves the public
within family hours we are only a
stone's throw away from this venue and
it would massively affect our mental
health our well-being and general
general living and yeah thank you thank
you miss gerald mr. Dave hasted have you
got any final comment nothing further to
add thank you thank you and miss Allison
you'll find comment yes thank you yes
thank you I feel very strongly about
having this position removed because of
the impact it will have on our lives
given we are in such close proximity to
the building nowhere along has only
clothes on is there a bar that is this
close to residential properties with
late of broking hours and the removal of
this condition we'll just further those
hours I would like to ask the committee
to please
looking so further reducing the off cows
license to 1900 hours thank you thank
you very much the applicant and agent
and representative like to sum up please
yes thank you very much indeed this is a
slightly strange hearing as their as the
committee is no doubt by now picked up
he teased addressing an anomaly in
essence is hugely important to keep
focused on that fact because the way
that the representations have been
developed is along the lines of
revisiting the grants of the license
that and decisions that were made back
in March this is a quality proposal by
mr. glicks Fixman and it has been
granted we are exclusively concerned
with this particular condition and it's
really the one condition as as opposed
to - - and it's an anomaly that turns on
alcohol and table meal and that is what
the committee will really need to focus
on and that's what my representation
earlier was all about what real
difference does he actually make to make
people eat
food how much food we don't know with
alcohol as opposed to people enjoying a
glass of wine or a beer or whatever else
it may be in the context of sitting in
mr. Glickman's proposed restaurant in
the future looking out over the sea or
from his current survival and of course
that is the context of this application
and that is also hugely important
because the committee needs to make the
decision as things stand now an officer
Dylan referred to the Hope and Glory
case it's a very important case he
picked up on a relevant paragraph it's
in the applicants pack as well it's more
just as tools as paragraph at 42 which
explains as I said earlier the 360
degree nature of a licensing decision in
which the views and the wishes of local
people are important but they're not
exclusive and the importance of
stimulating demand the importance of
local economy the importance of
providing a service the importance of
local business are all relevant
considerations that they're not to be
disregarded but it keeps coming back to
this condition and miss lane for
environmental health told you that this
application was all about effect on
licensable activities that's not correct
it's very closely the effect of this
application the the effect on the
licensing objectives of this particular
condition so to spread it out wider and
say that this becomes something to do
with controlling noise in the court yard
controlling behavior or limiting it to
nine o'clock that goes to move far as
the committee have a no doubt picked up
and and in actual fact that the planning
permission becomes relevant again
because if that has yet to go through
officer Dillon said removing this
condition automatically
that gives the rights and turn this into
a pub well it does not because the
planning use is a three which is not a
poll so regardless of the decision of
this committee today that control
remains these premises can only be a
cafe restaurant until planning say
differently and so that control that
remains and that is to be decided
another day there that's hugely
important for this committee to take
into account because they are absolutely
not giving the right for these premises
to be a pub or an exclusive drinking
establishment or a late-night
establishment by affecting this
condition the condition relates only to
the the ability to to trade within the
planning control so a three at the
moment the application and I refer to it
because miss lane again referred to it
the application for planning is for
mixed use and again it's planning it's
not licensing which is to be absolutely
clear about that what that was in a
looks uses that you must maintain a
balance you cannot turn exclusively to
one or the other because then you
challenge your use class and you're in
breach of your planning so in terms of
questioning mr. Dixon's motivation the
very of the mixed nature of the planning
application tells you what you want to
do but quite frankly as a reputable
businessman in the locality he's
entitled to be believed on his own terms
he's entitled to have credit for what he
say you he's never been demonstrated to
be anything other than straightforward
before as I say he gets involved in
community events he gets involved in
community charities he has told you what
he wants premises to survive in thought
but to trade effectively in the long
term if for any reason in the future
that becomes different it becomes
something that he said it would not be
at that point there is a review
application and that is something else
that he's very important comes out in
the case or the same case or the officer
didn't referred to the
and licensing can be a light type regime
and you can say yes and give the benefit
of the doubt is because there is always
that facility for the police for
environmental health for any one of the
residents to come back and say that
hasn't worked out and here is the
evidence and that's the word that the
officer used over and over again you
need evidence and that's what would
occur if you needed to make a review
then the officers Environmental Health
Police whoever else would be able to
come back and say we have evidence of
something that has gone wrong and at
this stage we can revisit ours we can
revisit conditions we can revisit the
scope of the license we can do all sorts
of things at this point as the officer
has made very very clear there is no
evidence unless the Glicksman is
entitled be taken at his word this is
not a sleepy seaside cafe environment
I'm informed that there was a nightclub
very close to this location some time
ago that he's now no longer there this
is a preferable option through a return
to a nightclub or a pub which mr.
Glicksman says he will not do but in any
event sleep PC sites as your corporate
priorities no doubt continually remind
you do not fare very well and they do
not fare particularly well coming out of
a global pandemic and in terms of
recovery and in terms of boosting local
economy and paying for local services
and local resources you need successful
businesses that will pay their tax pay
their rates provide employment
opportunities these are not
insignificant considerations at this
point in time essentially that decision
has been made in March this is just
tying up loose ends nothing more nothing
less
needs do you know is not a consideration
the removal of the condition in reality
will make precious little difference to
the decision that has already been made
and I commend
to you in the hands of a man who knows
what he's doing
he's highly experienced he's got no
blemish against his name he's got a
tried and tested track record this isn't
a an unknown speculative venture you can
balance it against the other premises
that he has in the town and judge him by
what he does not just what he says and
have the confidence that these premises
will actually become the the very
attractive proposition that he has
exactly the kind of place actually that
local residents mayro will appreciate as
and when they come to fruition hopefully
when economic times are better and it
will become that friendly local
restaurant that people are proud to have
in their town that's the situation at
this point in time that's the reason
this condition condition needs tidying
up because it's a problem it's important
for everybody including the enforcing
authorities at this point in time and
that is why this application has been
brought to you and I commend it strongly
to you thank you thank you and this mr.
geekman wants to add anything to that no
thank you I think this group has said
everything I needed thank you thank you
very much that ends the representations
thank you all very much the members of
the subcommittee will now leave this
meeting along with the council's legal
representative to deliberate this matter
in private we shall resume here to
deliver a verdict in 30 minutes time
whilst we leave the meeting I will ask
the committee services manager to
explain the retiring process thank you
Thank You chairman now for benefit of
the members of public watching on the
council's YouTube channel is I'll be
stopping this stream the stream will
remain the YouTube stream will remain
live and it will come back on again in
half an hour's time so that is due 1212
so I shall stop the stream now
xn chair over to you we're all live and
up and running again okay
Thank You Nick welcome back everyone
I would now like to invite Gavin Happ
interim senior litigation wire to read a
summary of the subcommittee's
determination Thank You councillor
Corrigan the determination of the
subcommittee
hermès as follows this was an
application to very premises license
number L in 2005 one one eye relating to
premises known as st. Mildred by Beyonce
Kent CTIA
ad the applicant mr. Paul Glicksman
represented by Miss Sarah clover as
applied to vary his premises license by
way of deleting two conditions and she
currently on the premises to license one
intoxicating liquor shall not be sold or
supplied on the premises other than two
persons piking table meals there and for
consumption by such a person as an
ancillary to his meal and tow it is an
implied condition of his license that
suitable beverages other than
intoxicating liquor including drinking
yet equally available Thornton spoken
with or as an ancillary to may all
served in the licensed premises in
considering this application we have
concentrated on the substance of this
application the sake mrs. Raymond on
this occasion to consider other issues
including the hours of operation of
these premises
subcommittee has been informed that the
group bringing them has been remote as
well as two additional Kent lesions have
been proposed and agreed by the
applicant
these conditions are one all off sales
of alcohol shall be supplied in non
glass containers with the exception of
any style of alcoholics for delivery by
or delivery service or any alcohol
the customer may not just strike up ie
an unfinished bottle of why
and turn the hours of off sale shall be
limited to between ten hundred hours and
twenty two hundred hours seven days a
week we've heard or received evidence
from the applicant the Environmental
Health Officer Kemp police the RNLI and
a number of local residents including a
considerable number of written
representation we also know who the West
Gate on C Town Council supported outplay
trick we have paid very close attention
to all the material and evidence which
has been put before us will notice in
particular the local residents have a
genuine concern regarding of attention
for the operation of these premises to
resolve noise outbreak causing
prejudices prevention of public nuisance
licensing objective and we do not
minimize those concerns we've also
posted the guidance issued under Section
119 of the licensing an hour even three
stipulate we should accept the advice of
the place unless as relating to the
prevention of crime in disorder
the police have made it very clear that
there is no evidence which would
indicate that any of the licensing
objectives would be prejudiced worthy
excessively limit is an experienced
operator of licensed premises running as
he does
what understand the applicant intends
once the restrictions equation with
anyone indeed to operate the crisis as a
home or and restaurant in all the
circumstances and having considered all
of the evidence before us we are
satisfied this application can be
granted subject to the addition of the
two conditions agreed between the
applicant and police which we consider
to be appropriate and necessary for the
motion of the licensing objectives we
are satisfied the Licensing Act 2003
provides sufficient safeguards including
the mechanisms review the premises
license in the event of the operator of
these premises should fall short of the
aspiration mr. Glicksman has put before
this subcommittee tonight that's the
decision and subcommittee it we
circulated informative like work advice
thank you thank you Gavin
thank you to everyone that concludes the
business for this meeting of the
licensing subcommittee